wheels a beaucoup de monde s'est déplacé
pour entendre le délibéré
l'éleveuse a été condamné à deux ans de
prison dont un an avec sursis et mise à
l'épreuve et cinq ans d'interdiction
détenir des chiens cette condamnation
est un pas en avant pour les
associations qui luttent pour la cause
animale mais elle reste une déception
pour le propriétaire de poule j je vous
propose de les écouter
heureux parce que quelque part c'est
terminé un point en moins mais en même
temps je suis assez déçu ce que je la
trouvais enfin passé lourd de l'opep
voudrait que mon chien un vrai plus au
moins servir d'exemple qu'elles vont
commencer derrière c'est une victoire
pour nous parce que le juge est allé au
delà du réquisitoire du procureur
général
on s'attendait mais vraiment pas ça bien
évidemment qu'on espérait au fond de
nous avoir quelque chose de
d'exemplaires mais mais franchement
enfin je suis désolé c'est l'émotion qui
parle mais pour nous c'est vraiment une
honte mais c'est une avancée et c'est
une bouffée d'espoir énorme à la
clinique vétérinaire de louhans l'équipe
est apparue encore marqués par le
souvenir de fugee il avait passé neuf
jours en soins intensifs avant de mourir
d'une insuffisance rénale il avait mal
ou le soigner il attendait une caresse
et il a redemandé
ça c'est du lourd c'est vraiment très
dur du coup est ce que la condamnation
c'est ça soulage vous soulage ou pas
elle soulage parce que sa marque
effectivement le geste il est condamné
c'est pas bien c'est grave je vais pas
revenir fugee malheureusement l'éleveuse
est ressorti libre du tribunal
elle devra également verser 1500 euros à
son ex compagnon et un euro symbolique
aux associations parties civiles dans ce
procès